So now that we're logged
in to our cloud shell,
let's take a look at how we manage
applications without Docker.
We'll kick this off by creating a Ubuntu
VM to play around using the gcloud
compute instances create command.
Once our VM is created, we"ll log in
using the gcloud compute ssh command.
On our VM, let's use our native
package manager to install NGINX and
all of its dependencies.
First we'll have to make sure
everything is up to date on our system.
Now, with our system up to date, we're
going to install the NGINX web server.
And let's check the NGINX version.
Let's use systemd to start the NGINX
based on what we did previously.
Now I need to check that
the NGINX is actually running.
One way to do that is with
the systemctl command.
So I see that everything's
actually running.
I see the logs are telling
me everything looks right.
So now I should be able to hit
NGINX locally, using curl.
This is great.
So modern OSs make it really easy
to install applications, start, and
run them.